hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar use of surface plasmon
resonance for probing cell matrix
interactions I am to do hora
collaborates and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Reichert
technologies record technology's life
sciences boasts a rich legacy and optics
and refractometer e spanning nearly 140
years continually centered on generating
new ideas and technologies their purpose
is to keep providing the leading
innovations that empower you in your
ceaseless quest for discovery record is
a unit of Ametek incorporated a leading
global manufacturer of electronic
instruments and electromechanical
devices to learn more visit
www.hp.com/recycle open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
too large the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker research
assistant Michael Hill Michael earned a
Bachelors of Science and biomedical
engineering at the University at Buffalo
in 2012 he is now in his fourth and
final year pursuing a PhD in the
biomedical engineering in biomedical
engineering at the University at Buffalo
under adviser Deb John Sarkar PhD in the
laboratory of biomaterials
and regenerative therapeutics Michael
Hill will now begin his presentation
hello and thank you for joining me for
today's webinar on behalf of record
technology as I'm presenting the use of
surface plasmon resonance SPR for
probing cell matrix interactions we'll
begin with a brief introduction in a
discussion of our motivation in these
studies followed by part 1 the
characterization of the surface energy
of immobilized proteins using liquid
contact angle studies part 2 the test of
SPR for a nonspecific adhesion
application using endothelial cells and
part 3 a test of SPR for a specific
adhesion application using white blood
cells following will be our summary and
concluding remarks surface forces are
central aspects to cell adhesion there
are several classes of surface forces
which may be present or absent depending
on the nature of the solvent and the
material in contact with the biological
substance to begin with are the van der
Waals forces which are the long-range
nonspecific forces which exist between
all atoms and molecules the van der
Waals forces consists of the dispersive
force which is the interaction between
two spontaneously induced dipoles and is
quantum mechanical in nature the key
some force which is the classical force
between two permanent dipoles and the
Debbi force which is between a dipole
and a non dipole and is therefore the
dipole induced dipole force the second
class of surface forces I'd like to
discuss are the electric double layer
forces electric double layer forces
always exist in solution due to the
contact potential difference between a
material and a solvent they consist of a
short-range and very strong entropic or
electrostatic repulsion and under
physiological assault conditions they
fall off after about 10 angstrom
separation between material surfaces the
last class of surface forces I'd like to
discuss
are the Lewis acid Lewis bass
interactions also known as electron
acceptor electron donor interactions in
particular hydrogen bonding falls into
this class hydrogen bonds are very
short-range very strong and directional
forces which are semi quantum mechanical
in nature they typically fall off after
about three angstroms
the separation between material surfaces
in solution they can be either
attractive or repulsive lastly I'd like
to note that in situations of practical
interest proteins will arrive at in its
lower bond surfaces prior to cells
arriving and they will present their own
surface fields therefore it would be the
net sum interaction between all three
phases of material protein phase and
cell phase that determines the net bio
adhesive outcomes next I'd like to
discuss the difference between specific
and nonspecific forces in relation to
biological adhesion in the last slide we
discussed the nonspecific forces
specific forces are merely a particular
pattern or arrangement of the
short-range hydrogen bonding or
electrostatic forces as discussed they
fall off after about one nanometer under
physiological salt conditions
paradoxically then they can also be
defined by their ability to transmit
their effects across thick albumin
blankets whereas the nonspecific forces
are screened out or shielded by albumin
blankets one example of a system which
is thought to be a specific adhesion
system is the original glycerol aspartic
acid peptide also known as the rgd
peptide this peptide is found in serum
proteins such as fibrin acting which are
known to be cell adhesion molecules it
binds specifically with certain domains
of a family of protein called the
integrins which are cell membrane
proteins known to be involved in cell
adhesion the very strong bond is likely
formed due to the specific arrangement
of the polar a polar and polar amino
acids in the RGD peptide another example
which is more well known are receptor
ligand interactions which are well known
to
a lock-and-key type mechanism which is
similar to an ant
antigen-antibody type adhesion therefore
we wanted to determine whether spr could
be used to probe both kinds of
interactions using vascular biology
systems so first we have to answer what
is surface plasmon resonance an
evanescent wave is set up by shining
light with the resonant frequency of the
surface plasmon of the thin gold film
since this wave is a near field effect
which is traveling parallel to the
surface rather than perpendicular to it
molecules which are in the close
vicinity of the surface or actually
adsorbed on the surface will change the
local refractive index and this changing
signal can be measured by the SPR
instrument the range of the signal to
sun's changing refractive index is a few
hundred nanometers from the surface of
the chip in these studies we used a
Riker Sr 7500 DC model the advantage to
this instrument is as a modular tubing
and flow chamber system which is easy to
change the modular tubing is important
due to using cells which have a variety
of sizes and also higher concentration
cell solutions may cause aggregation and
clog tubing therefore a larger tubing
can be used if you are using a larger
cell size and the flow chamber can also
be switched out easily if it is getting
clogged there's a wide possible range of
flow rates with this instrument from a
few micro liters per minute to a few
mils per minute we also used a Riker SPR
gold chip that has a 10% carboxylic acid
ninety percent poly ethylene glycol
terminated self-assembled monolayers
coupled to the gold sensor chip this
allows us to use EDC NHS chemistry to
Amin couple proteins to the surface by a
reaction with the carboxylic acid in the
lower right hand side is a centigram
where Part A we flush EDC NHS over the
chip to activate it in Part B we flush
80 micrograms per mil of a protein
solution over to a mean cup
the protein to the surface and in Part C
we quenched the reaction with ethanol
amine as can be seen the signal
afterwards is higher than the signal
beforehand due to the higher refractive
index of the protein at the interface
the controlled shear and real-time
signal of SPR offer potential major
advantages to cell adhesion studies past
studies have used several different
methods to test for cell adhesion into
material or protein surfaces
the first method I'd like to discuss is
passive attachment with manual counting
in this method cells are allowed to
attach to a material surface under
quiescent conditions where gravity is
the only force operative the cells are
left for a predetermined amount of time
such as 24 or 48 hours when the material
is typically removed from culture and
the cells are fixed and stained from
their bright field or fluorescent
microscopy microscopy can be used to
manually count the cells the advantage
to this method is that is low cost and
is relatively easy to do however it is
very low resolution in terms of the
strength of the adhesive bond between
cell and protein or selling material
since there is no challenge to the
adhesive bond both loosely attached and
irreversibly bond cells will remain on
the surface and will be counted it also
does not mimic any natural situation and
then some challenge to the adhesive bond
will usually be present such as a shear
force therefore cell attachment under
defined shear has also been used a
viscometer or some type of flow chamber
with a defined shear profile can be used
to apply a force to the cells
the advantage to this method is that is
it is not that much more expensive than
passive attachment and that you can also
challenge the adhesive bond and get a
quantitative measure of the strength of
cell adhesion however we say that it is
low resolution because the material is
also removed from culture at some point
in time and the cells are simply counted
to get an estimate of the adhesion
strength therefore there is no real-time
signal on a short timescale of these
interactions occurring
the other method which has been used is
atomic force microscopy in brief a
single cell has to be attached to the
needle tip of an atomic force microscope
the cell is then brought within the
close vicinity of a material surface in
the strength of the interaction with
distance can be measured due to the
bending cantilever of the AFM tip the
cell can then be allowed to remain in
contact with a material surface for
different amounts of time and the pull
off strength can also be measured the
advantage to this is that it's obviously
very high resolution in terms of the
spatial and kinetic aspects of these
interactions
however atomic force microscopy is
expensive and this method is technically
challenging and takes a long time
therefore surface plasmon resonance
offers several advantages over previous
methods including that the cost and
complexity isn't that much higher you
can challenge the solid he Civ bond and
you have higher resolution with a
real-time signal which can give you a
signal every point 5 seconds of the
interaction in part 1 we estimated the
surface energy of three different
immobilized proteins on the SPR gold
chip to use SPR for a nonspecific cell
adhesion application in vivo endothelial
cells come into contact with two classes
of extracellular matrix proteins the
first is their own secreted basement
membrane which consists of mainly
collagen foreign laminin but also some
sulfated glycoproteins the second type
of tissue they come into contact with is
stromal tissue also known as connective
tissue which is the structural component
of tissues and consists mainly of
collagen 1 and 3 endothelial cells are
typically separated from the stromal
tissue by their own secreted basement
membranes under healthy conditions
however under pathological conditions
when either injury occurs or the
basement membrane can be thin due to a
cyclical challenge and the Sol's begin
to contact the stromal tissue
thus induces increased spreading and
pearl
operation of the endothelial cells and
they begin to invade the stromal tissue
forming new blood vessels the process
known as angiogenesis therefore the
question that we seek to answer is why
do the cells begin angiogenesis when
they contact the stromal tissue and why
does the basement membrane act as an
effective barrier to this process the
general physics of this is not well
understood therefore we use collagen one
as a model stromal protein we use Maitre
gel as a model basement membrane protein
and we use serum as a control protein
all three were immobilized onto the SPR
gold chips using the EDC NHS chemistry
after immobilization the chips were
washed with deionized water and allowed
to dry afterwards contact angle
measurements of a variety of diagnostic
liquids were measured to estimate the
bio surface energy using a rain heart
contact angle goniometer in brief
several polar and a polar diagnostic
liquid cecil drops are placed onto the
dry protein surface using a flamed
platinum wire to maintain the ultra pure
state of the diagnostic liquids an
average of six measurements is obtained
for each liquid the contact angle for
each liquid can then be used to relate
to the surface energy by a Young's
equation which is shown on the slide
gamma SV represents the solid vapor
surface energy while gamma SL represents
the solid liquid surface energy and
gamma LV represents the liquid vapor
surface energy where pi is the spreading
pressure of the adsorbed paper on the
biomaterial surface which in the case of
high-energy surfaces artificially masks
the high-energy surface there have been
several different surface energy
theories which are based on Young's
equation and relate the contact angle to
the surface energy of a biomaterial the
first we'd like to examine is this men's
critical surface tension in order to
obtain this men's critical surface
tension of a biomaterial
a series of diagnostic liquids contact
angles are measured with decreasing
surface tension
when a liquid which is completely
spreading is found it's surface tension
approximates the critical surface
tension of the biomaterial surface the
zisman plot is obtained by plotting the
cosine of the contact angle on the
y-axis and the surface tension of the
liquids on the x-axis a linear
regression is then performed to the
point of cosine theta equal to 1 which
gives the critical surface tension of
the biomaterial surface any diagnostic
liquid which is placed on this
biomaterial surface with surface tension
less than the critical surface tension
of the material will be completely
spreading with contact angle equal to
zero below the zisman plot is the buyer
curve the buyer curve purports to relate
the critical surface tension of a
biomaterial to the degree of biological
adhesion and retention under shear
materials which have critical surface
tension and the 2239 per centimeter
range R in the bio adhesive minimum and
we'll will retain little biological
substance under shear materials with
critical surface tension outside of this
range will have a higher potential for
biological adhesion and retention of
biological substance under a shearing
challenge the physics of a spreading
cell on a biomaterial surface can be
approximated by the physics of a
spreading cecil drop on a biomaterial
surface as pictured in the upper
right-hand corner for instance on low
energy surfaces such as silicon which
have critical surface tension of
approximately 25 Dynes per centimeter
and is squarely in the bio adhesive
minimum a polar diagnostic liquid placed
on the surface of silicone will remain
rounded additionally a self solution
placed on silicone the cells will also
remain rounded with a high contact angle
moving outside of the bio adhesive
minimum to the left-hand side where we
have our lowest energy surfaces which
are mainly fluorinated surfaces such as
Teflon cells will also remain rounded on
Teflon in the absence of serum
however the buyer curve only purports to
relate to the actual physiological
situation in terms of salt and protein
content
therefore in the presence of
physiological amounts of serum and salt
the cells will here tenaciously and
spread on Teflon surfaces the next
theory we'd like to be
to examine is Kelly's method also known
as method of Owens and when this theory
purports to split the surface energy of
materials into two distinct components
the polar and the dispersive component
either component may be present or
absent at a given liquid solid interface
the polar component consists of the key
summoned dubby forces according to this
theory materials which are dispersive
force dominated proteins will not absorb
and cells will remain rounded on
surfaces which have kisum and dubby
forces president proteins will adsorb in
cells will begin to spread on a material
surface like Sussman's critical surface
tension Cowboys method uses multiple
liquids and the equation is solved
numerous times for each possible liquid
pair the arithmetic average for each
component is taken in liquid pairs which
gave a value outside of the standard
deviation are rejected and the
calculation is repeated until all values
lie within the standard deviation the
next surface energy theory that we
examined is the most modern update to
surface energy theory van Osgood
Chowdhury Theory also abbreviated as vo
GCT according to this theory the key sum
the Debbi and the dispersive forces are
all lumped together into one component
the lifshitz van der Waals component
which is the a polar component of the
surface tension the so-called polar
component in this theory is the Lewis
acid Lewis base interactions which as
discussed includes hydrogen bonding
according to this theory two electron
donating surfaces will repel one another
whereas an electron accepting surface
can adhere to an electron donating
surface there are ways of using multiple
liquids for these calculations however
what is most widely used is two polar
and one a polar liquid which is out of
simplicity and three simultaneous linear
equations are solved to get each
component
of the solid surface energy first we
look at the systems critical surface
tension of the three immobilized
proteins on the SPR gold chips in a
distant plot when the linear trendline
has a more negative slope it indicates a
more a polar surface therefore examining
the dotted line which represents matron
gel we can see that mate Rogell was the
most a polar protein surface followed by
serum in collagen one was the most polar
protein surface we next examined cow
blues method by looking at the ratio of
the polar to the dispersive component as
a measure of the polarity it was seen
that collagen one had the highest ratio
and therefore was the most polar protein
surface followed by serum and Maitre gel
was the most a polar protein surface
this agreed exactly with the predictions
of the zisman plot finally we looked at
what the character of that polarity
might be by examining the type of
hydrogen bonding present on each protein
film we looked at the ratio of the Lewis
acid to the Lewis base character as a
measure of Lewis acidity collagen one
was the most acidic protein surface
followed by serum and Maitre gel was the
most mono polar basic protein surface we
next wanted to examine whether the
increased polarity and/or Lewis acidity
of the collagen one correlated with
increased interaction with cells we
first activated the chip using EDC NHS
as shown and then we immobilized each
protein solution at 80 micrograms per
mil as shown on the left hand inset as
can be seen by the dotted line which
represents Maitre gel matrix all
immobilized about four times more
protein than the other two protein
solutions which were similar we didn't
look for a reason for this but it is
likely simply due to the different
solution state confirmations of proteins
in each of these solutions we next
flushed a cell solution of ten to the
seventh cells per mil over each protein
surface at a share
flow of about 5 microliters per minute
which correspondent to a peak shear
stress of about point zero one Dynes per
centimeter squared as can be seen the
signal for collagen one increased very
rapidly represented by the dashed line
whereas Maitre gel hardly increased all
represented by the dotted line mature
gel actually increased a total of only
four hundred micro RI u units we allowed
the cell solution to flow over each
protein surface for 50 minutes upon
which time we reintroduce buffer and we
reduced the flow rate by half and
allowed the cells to interact and spread
on the surfaces for three hours as can
be seen when the flow rate was reduced
there was a sudden spike in the signal
for a Cal for collagen one but
especially for serum due to the reduced
shear challenge the cells began to
interact more fully with the protein
surfaces after three hours of spreading
we removed the gold chip from the
instrument and cultured it overnight in
endothelial cell medium at five percent
co2 we then fixed and stained the cells
with Debbie and phalloidin Debbie is a
nucleus staining molecule which should
cause the cell nucleus to fluoresce a
blue color phalloidin is an actin
cytoskeleton staining molecule which
should cause the actin cytoskeleton to
fluoresce a red color these studies
revealed that on each protein surface a
monolayer density of endothelial cells
was present after culturing overnight
therefore we concluded that the very
different SPR signals must have been due
to differences not in the number of
attached cells on each protein surface
but due to the differential kinetics of
spreading on each protein surface
therefore we use surface energy
measurements of protein films to predict
the optimal conditions for formation of
a confluent live endothelial cell mono
layer in particular the more polar
proteins that had higher Lewis acid
character will form monolayers more
efficiently mono layer formation will be
important spr studies where you use
specific
drugs or hyperosmolar or hypo osmolar
conditions to test the response of cells
we also found that cell binding was most
efficient when the extracellular matrix
proteins were immobilized at around pH
of 7 not Chell in our studies where we
try to optimize the EDC NH s amine
coupling of proteins by using proteins
in a reduced pH solution these cause
very few cells to adhere due to the
unfilial aaja chol denaturation of the
proteins at the lower pH next we used
spr to test the adhesive interaction of
endothelial cells to these 3 different
protein surfaces that have differential
surface energy characteristics we used
hyperosmolar shock studies to challenge
the adhesive bond between the cells and
the protein films briefly as before we
activated the chips with EDC NHS and we
immobilized each protein at 80
micrograms per ml we then flushed 10 to
the 7 cells per ml on the surfaces again
in a loud the self suspension to flow
for 50 minutes while cells attached we
then allowed cells to spread for 3 hours
before these studies the blue arrow
represents the introduction of 100
millimolar hyperosmolar mannitol
solution and the red arrow represents
the introduction of an isotonic heeps
buffer as can be seen by looking at the
dashed line which represents collagen 1
there is an initial spike in the signal
which is only a bulk shift due to the
different refractive index of the
hyperosmolar solution the signal then
clearly decreases over 20 minutes before
an isotonic steeped buffer is
reintroduced and the signal begins to
recover this effect was beautifully
reproducible in the case of collagen 1
however with Maitre gel in serum after
the first cycle there was hardly any
effect on the second and third cycles in
particular looking at the first cycle we
measured that collagen one signal
decreased approximately four times more
than Maitre gel in serum after 3
hyperosmolar shock
studies we again fixed and stained the
cells as before with Dappy in floyd n'
we then used fluorescence microscopy to
image the gold chips in the center where
the signal is actually measured and the
peak shear stress will be highest we
found that on the collagen one surfaces
a mono layer density of cells was still
present but they had a shrunken and
created appearance with retracted cell
membranes when we examined the maître
gel gold chips in the center of the
channel we found that there were no
cells attached so we instead imaged at
the entrance of the chamber we found
that the mono layer had holes in it and
that the cells were even more shrunken
and created than on collagen one for
serum when we examined the chip in the
center we found that cells were still
attached but they seemed to be
completely rounded with very few cells
being still completely spread these
studies confirmed that the interaction
of endothelial cells was highest with
collagen one and lowest on the maître
gel protein films therefore the higher
polarity and Lewis acidity of the
collagen one films may have correlated
with the increased cell adhesion of
endothelial elv endothelial cells this
is the condition in evil in vivo as
endothelial cells begin to undergo
angiogenesis due to contacting the
stromal tissue we hypothesized that this
could be due to these immobilized arrays
of alternating Lewis acid and Lewis base
groups for collagen 1 however form a
true gel it is well-known to have a
cross linked structure which may shield
the Lewis acid groups of the proteins in
the matrix L solution therefore the
Lewis acid groups could be internally
quenched and unavailable at the surface
to interact with diagnostic liquids or
endothelial cells approaching the maitre
gel surface we also used a simple
equation that has been used in the past
to relate the hyperosmolar shock effect
to the Youngs modulus of adhesion to the
cells on Maitre gel in collagen one
briefly all you have to do is measure
the diameter of the cells beforehand and
have after hyperosmolar shock and relate
this to the
situation of the hyperosmolar solution
we found that for Maitre gel the
estimated Young's modulus of adhesion
with 0.5 mega Pascal's intra collagen 1
it was approximately 2 mega Pascal's so
collagen 1 had a 4 times higher
interaction if as you remember collagen
1 SP our signal also decreased four
times more than that of maitre gel
likely due to the cells being four times
more spread at that time point these
results also correlate well with
previous AFM studies that measured the
Young's modulus of adhesion of cells to
various proteins and found that they are
on the order of a few mega Pascal's and
strength in part 3 we wanted to see if
SPR could also be used to test a
specific interaction between cells and a
protein which will occur across multiple
protein inter layers being the thick
blankets of albumin we wanted to use
another vascular biology system of
interest being the interaction between
the protein P selectin and the white
blood cell line HL 60 in vivo white
blood cells are recruited to specific
tissue sites upon injury or inflammation
the way that this is done is that the
endothelial cells which line those blood
vessels begin to express different
proteins than a healthy tissues blood
vessels in particular the family of
proteins known as these selectins
becoming expressed during situations of
inflammation upon cytokine or other
inflammatory molecule signaling the P
select and protein which is typically
stored in the cytoplasm of endothelial
cells is released to the cell membrane
and expressed into the blood flow from
there the P select and protein can
tether the white blood cells and allow
them to begin to roll across the
endothelium and interact more and more
with other adhesive proteins when the
interaction is strong enough the white
blood cell can transmigrate at the
endothelium and proceed through the
connective tissue to the site of
inflammation or injury
in our first study we wanted to
differentiate between the non specific
aspects of HL 60 adhesion and the
specific aspects there for EDC NHS was
used to activate both the left and right
channels of the instrument and a human
go antibody IgG was covalently
immobilized in both the left and right
channels after quenching the reaction
with ethanol amine P selectin was
allowed to bind in the left channel only
on the right hand side you can see the
changing signal as ten to the seventh HL
60 cells per ml are flowed over each
surface as you can see the increase in
the blank well is greater than that for
the P selectin we hypothesize that this
is due to the longer range of the
nonspecific forces compared to the very
strong but short-range interaction
between P CL and HL 60 under shear in
this situation we were flowing the cells
at 50 microliters per minute with a
shear stress of approximately 0.1 Dynes
per centimeter squared therefore in our
next study we used bovine serum albumin
blocking in order to see if PR could
still measure the cell signal when only
the specific interactions were being
probed in these studies we activated the
left channel with EDC NH s followed by :
covalently immobilizing the antibody
after quenching with ethanol amine P
select and was allowed to bind only on
the left channel in both channels were
then blocked with BSA which should leave
a thick albumin blanket on both surfaces
then to the seventh HL 60 per ml where
again flowed over both surfaces on the
right hand inset examining the dashed
line which is a difference curve between
the left and right channel so the
subtracted curve left - right we now see
an increase in this difference curve
which means that more cells were now
going on to the P select encoded surface
than the blank wall due to the screening
of the nonspecific forces of the SPR
chip we then just wanted to confirm the
specificity of this interaction we
isolated HL 60 cells with ma b ka PL 1
and incubated them for
25 minutes this should block the cell
surface receptors to pee selectin we
then flush 10 to the 7 cells per mil
over each surface again and looked at
the difference curve which now does not
increase indicating that the P select
and specificity had been isolated in the
previous studies we did one more control
experiment seen in the left hand inside
where we immobilized antibody on to both
the left and the right channel and we
allowed P selected to bind in the left
channel while 19 FC bound in the right
channel 19 FC is an IgG fragment which
should have no specific interactions
with the HL 60 cell membrane receptors
we then BSA blocked both channels and we
allowed 10 to the 7 cells per mil to
flow over both channels at the same flow
rate of 50 microliters per minute this
can be seen the P select and curve
increased much faster than the 19 FC
curve we then allowed for a dissociation
step where buffer alone flows over the
cells and we saw that the interaction
continued to increase we then introduced
another h HL 60 solution and this time
it still increased more on P selectin
but less so due to the presence of cells
already occupying adhesion sites on the
protein surface these two control
studies were able to confirm that SPR
measured the specificity of this
interaction across multiple protein
inter layers the significance of this is
seen when you look back to the range of
the SPR signal which is a few hundred
nanometers multiple protein inter layers
each layer can be tens of nanometers in
size and cells are also large colloidal
objects from anywhere from ten to a
hundred micron depending on the cell
line therefore it was important to
confirm the SPR can probe both
nonspecific interactions and specific
interactions and it can be used to
closely monitor the monitor the nature
by which cells spread on ligand bearing
substrates at a narrow distance and time
scale this is something that can't be
done with standard microscopes
therefore overall we used SPR to probe
cell matrix interactions in the context
of both a specific and nonspecific cell
adhesion system these two types of
adhesion often coexist in a particular
biological context and it's often
controversial as to which one is
dominant therefore SPR represents a
useful tool to further dissect these
intermolecular characteristics and
differentiate in different model systems
between specific and nonspecific effects
the advantage to SPR is the especially
increased information at short length
and time scales we also used
hyperosmolar shock studies in
conjunction with SPR to quantify the
strength of the adhesion of cells with
proteins this could represent a cheaper
simpler easier and method which can give
similar quantitative results to more
expensive methods such as atomic force
microscopy in the future it would be
very useful to be able to visualize the
cells as they are spreading on an SPR
gold chip this could enable an increased
correlation of the SPR signal to the
kinetics of cell spreading which here we
did only indirectly
additionally regeneration of the sensor
chip would represent a huge leap forward
however removing the cells while keeping
the immobilized protein intact may not
be possible if you use high shear to
remove the cells this may cause cohesive
rupture leaving fragments of the cell
membrane attached to the surface cells
are typically removed from surfaces
using digestive enzymes however this
would obviously alter the protein film
as well therefore a method which could
release the entire used up SPR chemistry
and renew it in a cheap and simple
fashion would also be helpful going
forward further model development is
also required for cell studies to get
kinetic on-off rates of cells SPR in the
past has typically been used to measure
the mono valent binding interactions
however when cells are attached to a
protein film they attach
multiple focal adhesion points and each
of these interactions is likely to be
multivalent in nature therefore more
mathematical development as well as
further research is required I would not
like to answer any questions that you
might have thank you Michael for your
presentation so a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
Michael will answer as many questions as
time permits our first question is does
the differential kinetics affect the
degree of adhesion and by what MOA T
does it remain constant um sorry I don't
know what you mean by differential
kinetics could it could we have some
elaboration on that I'm afraid um I'm
afraid there are no more specifics if
the person who submitted that question
would want to again you know in the
question box clarify that would be that
would be great so we'll hold that
question for further clarification the
next one is around slide 18 low pH will
also reduce the efficiency of the mi
bond formation how do you differentiate
the low pH denaturing and the reduced
chemical reaction we found
anytime we immobilize the proteins using
low pH more protein would become
immobilized to the surface whether this
is due to the efficiency of the reaction
or whether is a colloidal stability
phenomenon we're not sure but what we
were sure of is that whenever we would
use lower PHS we would get very little
cell adhesion using the same
concentrations as when we use
physiological PHS our interpretation is
that the proteins may have been
denaturing or they also may have been
coupling to the surface in a different
fashion maybe not specifically to that
reaction the next one has several parts
I'll weed the whole thing and then let
me know if you need me to read anything
over wondering if primary mouse bone
marrow cells could be evaluated with
this matrix once attached to a tissue
could let's see
this mech matrix what's attached to a
tissue culture plate will it begin to
differentiate and would it be possible
to evaluate the rate of cellular
differentiation using SPR changes I'm
not from
with a specific cell line um I'm trying
to understand exactly what the question
meant but if you have a cell which is
more differentiated if it is more spread
then that's something that SPR could
measure compared to cells which are more
aggregated in terms of the fine detail
of how the cell is attaching to the
surface
how many focal adhesion points and how
that relates to changing SPR signal
there's been a little bit of work done
on that but it's still an open question
as far as I know so the the first
question the first question does the
differential kinetics affect the degree
of occasion and by what'n sorry about
that
does the defer to the first question
does the differential kinetics affect
the degree of adhesion and by what motif
does it remain constant little
clarification on that he's asking the
degree of adhesion in reference to the
kinetics I hope that's helpful I think I
understand the question although I'm
still not positive but like I mentioned
right as of right now as far as we know
there are no models that exist to get
kinetic on off data of cells so
everything that we did was indirect by
trying to see if there were equal
numbers of cells immobilized after
overnight culture and it seemed to be
the case
so we basically attributed the kinetics
of the changing SPR signal to the
spreading of the cells I'm not sure if
that answers the question while we're
reading
more questions to come in I would like
to once again thank Michael Hill for his
Michael do you have any final comments
thank you for joining me for this
webinar today thank you for listening it
was really fun to present this subject
to you today and have a good day okay so
can I show an example of flowing cells
over a protein on a surface and we have
one example of a study where we first
immobilized cells on a surface human
embryonic kidney cells and we captured
them on the surface and then we flowed a
fibrinogen solution over the cell
surface and tried to measure the
kinetics of the fibrinogen solution
actually binding to the cells and we
were able to get some kinetic on off
data but we obviously need to do more
studies in the future to confirm this
okay I have another question for you
Michael how does the concentration of
protein compare to physiological
conditions and is this important to your
results sure that's a very good question
actually so we are mobilizing these
proteins on to a goal SPR chip and
obviously that's not the physiological
condition of tissues tissues are
multiple layers of protein and a
macroscopic gel like State and they are
typically under stress in the condition
of which groups are which groups of the
amino acids or the protein backbone are
revealed are not revealed isn't certain
as far as I know
so in these studies we're trying to just
find a correlation which could possibly
be related for instance if we do major
gel experiments on mobilizing Maitre gel
many different ways when we find that in
all cases we aren't getting access to
different polar groups then we can
probably conclude that some
cross-linking effect is shielding these
polar groups from the surface of the
material lowering in contact angle
measurement is directly proportional to
rate of cell adhesion achieved with the
SPR method correct and that is that is a
question sorry it's a little bit more
complicated since these surface energy
measurements all come from the contact
angle of multiple polar in a polar
liquids if you wanted to just simplify
it I would say yes however some of the
theories go into more specific aspects
such as you can have a surface which you
will have a low contact angle because
your diagnostic liquid was basic and
your surface was acidic but you will
have a higher contact angle if your
liquid is acidic and your surface is
acidic but the surface may still adhere
cells more so and this also depends on
different cell lines expressing
difference in different amounts of
acidic and basic groups on their
surfaces okay I would like to now and
the presentation thank you I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed after the presentation
we would also like to thank our sponsor
Reichert technologies for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through march
20th 2017 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye